super simple super quick oh i can eat
this all day so today i'm going to be
challenging myself i'm going to attempt
to make all three of my meals using only
five key ingredients eggs potatoes
tomatoes onions and flour i'll also be
using water oil salt and pepper and
that's because i need water and oil to
be able to cook and salt and pepper
because unseasoned food isn't that great
all of these recipes will be available
on tasty.com and if you're one of those
people who comments about never having
the right ingredients try the what's in
your kitchen feature on the tasty app
you can put in up to three ingredients
that you have in your pantry and it'll
show you a bunch of recipes you can make
let's get started
i'm making eggs in purgatory which is
just eggs poached in a tomato sauce my
pan just warming up over medium heat now
i'm adding my olive oil once my oil is
at temperature i'm going to add my
onions and i'm just letting these go
about five minutes until they're nice
and soft so i am adding
water cherry tomatoes
adding some salt pepper pepper pepper
pepper pepper
toss those make sure everything is nice
and coated at this point you can also
add whatever vegetables and spices you
may want garlic peppers whatever i'm not
adding any because it doesn't fit into
my five ingredients but you can do
whatever you want at this point will
this fit oh i need a bigger lid and i'm
just going to cover
i don't have a lid that's big enough to
fit on this pan so i'm just going with
what i got and i'm gonna let this go for
about five to seven minutes are you
hungry
it's been about seven minutes so far and
my tomatoes are just starting to fall
apart you don't want them to completely
break down you want them to remain a
little bit chunky add a little bit of
that texture there what i'm going to do
is i'm going to make little wells in
my tomato
hit it with a little salt
pepper i'm just going to let this go for
about five to six minutes until my
whites are set but my yolk is still a
little bit runny that's all it takes to
make eggs in purgatory super simple
super quick hey liz
you hungry
oh my god
thank you let's take a bite on camera
yeah oh my god
it's so good
oh hell yeah the tomatoes and onions are
nice and jammy and the eggs are nice and
runny this is a great way to start the
day
[Music]
it is lunchtime which means i'm going to
be making something a little bit more
intensive a tortilla espanola you can
have it for breakfast you can have it
for lunch you can have it for dinner you
can even have it as a snack get my
burner on medium-high heat and i'm going
to add a lot of olive oil
and i want my oil to just start to
shimmer a little bit
so i'm going to add
my potatoes
as well as my onions
and my salt
so you can actually see some of my
potatoes and onions sticking up from
underneath the oil you want everything
to be submerged so feel free to add more
oil as you go just to make sure
everything is nice and covered at this
point i'm just going to let everything
cook until it's fork tender which will
take roughly five to seven minutes i
just want to test
with one
and that is fork tender right there so
my potatoes are cooked at this point so
i just need to get it off the heat and
get everything strained ever so
carefully
that chill off to the side while my
potatoes are chilling i'm going to get
started on my egg mixture i have a large
bowl here in which i'm going to crack
six eggs
uno dos
a little bit of salt some pepper pepper
pepper you're going to want to whisk for
about two to three minutes at this point
i'm going to bring back my cooled potato
and onion mixture add those back and
then i'm just going to fold all of this
together this needs to sit for about
five minutes at this point that's really
going to allow your potatoes to soak up
your egg mixture this is a great time to
add any other ingredients you want in
your tortilla meats vegetables you name
it this is all i'm going to have but
feel free go wild and customize it
however you want my ingredients have had
a moment to get to know each other over
about medium heat i am adding three
tablespoons of my reserved oil i am
going to add my potato and egg mixture
just get that nice and even not all to
cook at about the same time and i'm
letting this go for about four to five
minutes until the edges get nice and
lacy
this looks great
oh where's my thing
i need to get my tortilla out of here
flipped and then back into the pan so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
kill the heat i'm going to
remove my pan add a heat proof bowl
to the top and this next part just do it
as confidently as possible do it in one
motion if you can
baby get my heat back on i'm going to
add one more tablespoon of my oil slide
this guy
right back in and i'm just going to go
around and tuck all the sides in so it
looks nice now this is flipped i'm gonna
let it go for about two to three minutes
until it's cooked through oh my god that
smells so good i think this bad boy is
good
i'm going to slide it out
not quite done yet i'm gonna let this
rest for about five to ten minutes and
then i can cut it up and serve it you
guys ready to eat yes
you guys sound like you're dying
a little bit of olive oil a little bit
of pepper
some coarse salt all right what do we
think
it's delicious that's amazing 10 out of
10 recommend
[Music]
they're real good the potatoes are nice
creamy and warm and it's salty and oh i
can eat this all day it's like a quiche
if a quiche met a scalloped potato all
right i will see you guys at dinner time
i am going to use all five of my
allotted ingredients to make potato
gnocchi with a quick tomato sauce i have
a pot of water here already at a nice
boil i'm going to add salt and i'm going
to lower
my potatoes in
i'm going to let these go for about 20
to 25 minutes just until they're tender
enough to pierce the fork in the
meantime i'm going to get started on my
sauce i have a pan here over medium heat
and i'm adding my olive oil i'm adding
my onions and i'm letting these cook for
about five to seven minutes my onions
are nice and soft which means it's time
to add my tomatoes so i'm going to let
these go until they start to burst much
similar to how i made the eggs in
purgatory in the morning all i have left
to add to this is water and just a
splash more olive oil if you want to add
more to your sauce you totally can you
can add garlic you can add all sorts of
herbs to it i'm going to let this go for
about 15 minutes so the tomatoes can
break down and cook down and form a
cohesive sauce
i'm ready to start making my gnocchi at
this point and you can use a ricer
potato masher anything that gives you a
cohesive broken down potato that looks
good enough to me scrape off any of the
excess
and to add my one egg
incorporate this until just
barely combined
i'm ready to start adding my flour a
little bit at a time and you want to be
careful when you're making gnocchi that
you're not overworking the dough both
these be light and pillowy and fluffy
and not dense and gummy and chewy so i'm
pretty happy with my dough at this point
it's kneaded but not overworked and it's
not sticky anymore you can see there's
barely anything coming off of my fingers
so i'm ready to start forming my gnocchi
i'm going to sprinkle a little bit of
flour on my work surface
plop my dough down onto it i'm going to
cut
in half and then i'm going to cut
that in half i got four equal pieces
set these
babies aside and then i'm just going to
roll
this out
i'm just going to cut this guy in half
and keep working it down
so we're going to boom
boom
so these are my little gnocchi here
scoop these guys up transfer them to a
flower sheet i'm going to finish up with
the rest of them and there they are
there's a couple things you can do at
this point first and foremost you can
leave them as is or if you want to make
them a little bit fancier you can roll
them off the edge of a fork or in some
cases i have this handy little gnocchi
board here since i've been cooking all
day i'm just going to leave these as is
throw them in some boiling water and put
it all together i'm just going to make
sure it's nice and salted you want salty
like the ocean i'm just going to add my
gnocchi in drop them in
drop them in
these don't need that much time to cook
you just want them to float to the
surface and then you can pull them so
let's pull these guys
and i'm just going to reserve a little
bit of that cooking water it's got all
that starch in it and now i'm ready to
put together my gnocchi and my sauce
i've got my tomato sauce reheated i'm
just going to add a little bit of my
pasta water get that nice incorporated
of course i'm going to add back my
gnocchi come on
ah
there you have it as you can see my
sauce is really really thickened from
that starchy water and at this point
your gnocchi's done
who's hungry
come here
thank you thank you friend
it's only pretty good
it's great you're great thank you you're
great too i love you i love you thank
you no not you the gnocchi's really good
it's super light and super fluffy the
sauce is really really sweet and really
really good despite there being so
little in it this is an awesome way to
end the day and there you have it three
meals using the same five ingredients we
had the jammy eggs in purgatory for
breakfast the comforting filling
tortilla espanola for lunch and we
closed things out with the easy yet
show-stopping gnocchi which one was your
favorite and would you be interested in
seeing more challenges like this let me
know in the comments below all of these
recipes will be available on tasty.com
and give the what's in your kitchen
feature on the tasty app a try if you
need some inspiration oh yes
[Music]
you